Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Priel Korenfeld
Buon pomeriggio!
Io sono un medico,
mi occupo di nefrologia,
di malattie dei reni -
e magari vediamo insieme,
più avanti, anche questo tema.
Però volevo raccontarvi, e iniziare,
dal perché ho voluto fare il medico.
Perché per me era importante,
sin da piccolo,
riuscire a comprendere
le varie sfaccettature della vita.
Sì, la parte organica, le malattie;
ma anche la parte psicologica,
gli aspetti emozionali, le culture.
Arrivo da una famiglia in cui i miei nonni
avevano fatto la guerra,
e mi hanno raccontato molto
di questi aspetti.
E quindi, riuscire a comprendere
come sia possibile
che l'uomo arrivasse a certe situazioni
per me è stato sempre importante.
Io la guerra non l'ho vissuta,
quindi ho pensato che fosse utile
fare delle esperienze
nei paesi in via di sviluppo,
nei paesi in guerra,
per comprendere le culture,
le religioni locali
e come gli uomini
interagiscano l'un l'altro.
Perché la dinamica dei gruppi
condiziona la società, ovviamente.
In questa slide -
non sono io quello nell’immagine,
avrei troppi capelli,
ma rappresenta il percorso
che io percepisco necessario
per comprendere l'indole umana.
Un percorso difficile, cupo, ombroso, vero?
Però mio nonno mi diceva sempre -
il nonno che ha fatto la guerra-
quando dovrai fare una scelta,
scegli sempre la strada più difficile.
Mai quella più facile.
E per scegliere una strada difficile
come questa scalinata
ci vuole coraggio, ovviamente,
ma ci vuole anche curiosità;
determinazione, ma anche
una certa dose di incoscienza.
E quindi, per raggiungere quell'obiettivo,
magari insieme adesso
cerchiamo di capire alcuni passaggi.
Qua siamo a Giacarta
dove una manifestazione pacifica
si trasforma, incomprensibilmente,
in una rissa collettiva.
I gruppi sono complessi,
le dinamiche delle persone,
all'interno dei gruppi, sono complesse
e creano delle situazioni imprevedibili
e spesso non replicabili.
E soprattutto,
le dinamiche e le azioni
dei singoli membri all'interno del gruppo
non corrispondono quasi mai
alle azioni e alle dinamiche del gruppo.
Ognuno di noi, da solo,
si comporterebbe in maniera diversa
rispetto a come si comporta in gruppo.
E certe volte in maniera opposta,
da come si comporta il gruppo.
E questo crea una difficoltà enorme
nell'[analisi scientifica],
che necessità la replicabilità,
e quindi non riusciamo
a comprendere completamente
quali siano le dinamiche dei gruppi.
Ci sono stati alcuni esperimenti sociali:
questo è un esperimento di Hash.
Qual è la linea più lunga?
La quattro, ovviamente.
Bene, se io prendo questa immagine,
la metto in una classe,
e addestro tutti i partecipanti a dire
che la linea più lunga è la seconda,
e poi chiamo una persona ignara,
vittima dell'esperimento,
e comincio a chiedere a tutti quanti
quale è la linea più lunga,
e tutti, ovviamente, dicono: la due.
Arrivato il suo turno, lui risponderà,
nel 75% delle volte, la numero due,
Quindi solo il 25 % di voi,
25 persone su 100
avrebbero il coraggio di uscire
dalle dinamiche di gruppo.
Sto uscendo dal centro rosso...
Uscire dalle dinamiche
di gruppo - perché questo?
Perché noi abbiamo bisogno
di essere accettati dal gruppo,
perché essere accettati dal gruppo
vuol dire essere protetti.
E abbiamo bisogno di protezione,
di una zona di comfort.
e quindi nel 75% delle volte
scegliamo la strada più facile.
Non quella più difficile,
come invece diceva mio nonno.
E questo cosa comporta?
Comporta il fatto che non siamo
più liberi di pensare,
non riusciamo ad emanciparci.
Tutti parliamo di emancipazione femminile,
e delle persone, eccetera.
"Emancipazione" vuol dire essere
liberi dalle costrizioni di pensiero.
Il 75% di noi non è emancipato.
Questo è il problema.
Quindi, cosa succede?
Diventiamo vittime del potere,
delle autorità, dei media.
E diventiamo pedine!
Quindi non più attori della nostra vita,
e quindi frustrati.
Perché chi fa una vita
che non è la propria
diventa frustrato, non è contento,
è insoddisfatto della vita.
E questo crea un enorme problema
nella società, e quindi nei gruppi.
E allora, facendo tutte queste mie
sperimentazioni mentali e anche sociali
ho cercato di pensare:
qual è il luogo migliore
per provare a vedere
se ci sono delle strade
per rendere noi stessi
più gratificati da quello che facciamo.
E l'ambiente lavorativo
è il posto migliore:
noi basiamo tutta la nostra vita,
sostanzialmente, tra lavoro e famiglia.
E se guardiamo le ore,
siamo più al lavoro che in famiglia.
Dunque, nelle mie analisi,
ho cercato di capire quali fossero
i pilastri, le dinamiche migliori
per raggiungere uno stato
di gratificazione nell'ambito lavorativo.
E mi sono imbattuto in questo.
Impronunciabile, vero?
Csíkszentmihályi.
È il nome di uno psicologo.
È il nome di uno psicologo,
ed è uno dei più importanti psicologi
nell'ambito della felicità.
È ungherese, naturalizzato americano.
E ha teorizzato lo stato di "Flow",
cioè il coinvolgimento emotivo massimale,
la trance agonistica.
Tutti voi in qualche maniera,
nella vostra vita,
siete stati immersi in qualche cosa
tanto che niente vi poteva distrarre.
Si o no?
Avrete avuto, qualche volta,
un esperienza di questo tipo,
magari nei giochi.
Quello è la trance agonistica,
il momento a cui tutti noi
dovremmo arrivare
per essere imbattibili.
Ma non solo:
per far coincidere l'obiettivo personale
con quello del gruppo.
Perché noi raggiungiamo lo stato di "Flow"
quando il nostro gruppo, grazie a noi,
raggiunge la massima performance.
Quindi dobbiamo fare in modo
che il nostro obiettivo
sia lo stesso del gruppo.
E per fare questo,
ci sono quattro pilastri.
Fare questo vuol dire arrivare al flow,
che in questo caso è rappresentato
dal fiore di loto.
Il fiore di loto lo conoscete?
Lo avete mai visto?
È un fiore splendido, bellissimo
che nasce sugli stagni,
sulle pozze putride, sull'acqua stagnante.
È la rappresentazione ideale
dell'essere umano
che fa le cose più orrende al mondo,
distrugge tutto quello che può trovare
e poi crea le sinfonie di Beethoven,
crea l'arte più incredibile;
non solo, la tecnologia che ci permette
di viaggiare nello spazio!
Però, contemporaneamente,
tutto questo nasce
su una situazione tremenda, se ci pensate:
guerre, interessi personali,
violazioni dei diritti umani.
Bene, il primo pilastro
è il pilastro "Teal".
Teal vuol dire colore verde acqua,
la foglia del tè.
Ed è stata teorizzata da Frédéric Laloux.
È un concetto di organizzazione aziendale,
in cui il meccanismo
non è verticale ma orizzontale,
dove non c'è un capo che comanda
ma un insieme di gruppetti di persone
che decidono autonomamente alcuni passaggi
per rendere al massimo
la produzione e la qualità di vita
all'interno dell'azienda.
Tanto che è paragonabile
a un sistema quasi vivente,
in cui i gruppetti sono le cellule.
E il sistema aziendale "Teal" si muove
non con un business plan e un obiettivo,
ma si muove con la crescita
di questi gruppi
che poi portano all'obiettivo
che magari è diverso da quello iniziale.
Sembra una cosa utopica, vero?
Pensate sia possibile?
Michelin, Decathlon,
Patagonia, Harley Davidson
sono tutte organizzazioni "Teal".
Le persone all'interno
della vera organizzazione "Teal"
addirittura scelgono il loro stipendio
a seconda di quanto hanno prodotto
nel mese [in cui devono essere pagati],
tanto sono responsabilizzati,
tanto è diffusa la responsabilizzazione
del sistema.
Ma per essere veramente "Teal",
bisogna saper comunicare:
secondo pilastro.
Comunicare vuol dire, ovviamente,
essere trasparenti, dirci tutto,
comunicare gli obiettivi:
ma non è solo questo.
Esiste una teoria psicologica
che è il "sistema dell’enneagramma",
non so se lo avete mai sentito,
che divide le persone
in tre diverse tipologie:
istintuali, emotivi e razionali.
Le persone all'interno di questi gruppi,
quando si parlano,
nella stessa lingua ovviamente,
non percepiscono esattamente
le stesse sfumature.
E spesso nascono delle incomprensioni.
Se io sono un istintuale
per me amare una persona
vuol dire fare in modo di metterla
vicino a me, se ho un problema,
e di combattere insieme
per risolvere il suo problema.
Insieme a lei. Ok?
Questo, per me, vuol dire amare.
Per un razionale, amare vuol dire:
"Ti stimo", ma ti stimo talmente tanto!
Per un emotivo, invece,
ha un aspetto più romantico,
"del fiore".
Non è che le persone
vogliano dire qualcosa di diverso,
in fondo è la stessa cosa;
ma l’interpretazione è diversa.
Bene, quindi se io conosco come,
soprattutto nei concetti astratti,
le tre personalità
si parlano e si interpretano,
allora a questo punto io sono in grado
di riuscire a comunicare
molto meglio dentro il sistema.
E poi abbiamo gli altri due pilastri,
anche loro con delle analogie fra di loro.
Il primo è quello della leggerezza,
e leggerezza non vuol dire superficialità.
L'ha teorizzata Italo Calvino
nelle "Lezioni Americane" di Harvard.
Leggerezza vuol dire che -
vi ricordate la scalinata iniziale?
Quando io devo cominciare
a fare quella scalinata,
ombrosa, tenebrosa,
difficile, lunga e faticosa
non posso partire
con uno zaino completamente pieno,
altrimenti mi fermo al primo scalino.
Leggerezza significa che,
per qualsiasi percorso,
noi dobbiamo salire
con uno zaino vuoto per i primi scalini
e poi, pian piano, abbiamo tutto il tempo
di aggiungere ostacoli
e complicazioni varie.
Che normalmente arriveranno,
ma più in alto siamo
e più siamo vicini allo stato di Flow.
E se siamo vicini allo stato di Flow,
siamo imbattibili.
Quando voi raggiungete lo stato di Flow,
in qualsiasi situazione sia,
nessuno vi può battere.
Ricordatevelo, questo.
"Gamification": l'avete sentita prima.
È la metodologia migliore
per imparare lo stato di Flow.
Nella vostra esperienza personale
voi avrete avuto tante possibilità,
ma nel gioco -
tanto è vero che si chiamava
"trance agonistica", inizialmente -
nel gioco, raggiungete
più facilmente lo stato di Flow,
quindi il gioco serve
per fare team building,
per conoscersi bene,
per avere tutta una serie di interazioni
più vicine l’uno con l’altro,
nell’ambito lavorativo;
ma serve perché voi impariate
che cosa significa trance agonistica,
coinvolgimento massivo.
Nel gioco la raggiungete
molto più facilmente.
Io ho imparato la trance agonistica
con la mia macchina.
Questo è il quadrante
della mia automobile,
e mi sono accorto
che, [da] anni, mi sfidava
e io non capivo che stavo giocando.
Questa linea orizzontale, la parte bianca,
identifica il mio consumo;
io accelero, e aumenta la parte bianca.
Il rombo è la media:
ogni volta che io accelero,
non devo superare quel rombo
altrimenti la macchina
comincia a friggermi.
Fa dei rumorini strani,
beep-beep, eccetera eccetera.
Ma il problema è che quella è una media!
E quindi, meno io raggiungo quel rombo,
come vuole la mia macchina,
più quel rombo si sposta a sinistra
e quindi mi rende il gioco
sempre più difficile, ovviamente!
Cioè ero arrivato ad un punto
in cui tutti mi suonavano dietro
perché non acceleravo più,
perché non vincevo sulla macchina.
Alla fine del gioco, però,
io consumo 300/400 km in meno a pieno,
solo giocando ogni volta
con questo sistema.
Ma perché vi sto raccontando
tutta questa cosa?
Perché tutta questa cosa
che è stata teorizzata
tutto sommato è stata
messa in pratica in due aspetti:
uno, la fondazione Auxilia.
In dieci anni si è diffusa
in tutto il mondo,
e abbiamo fatto una serie
di attività umanitarie,
artistiche e culturali
che adesso non vi sto a dire
per mancanza di tempo.
Qui vedete poi due articoli di giornale:
il primo parla di una bambina soldato
che noi abbiamo tolto,
durante la guerra civile, dal carcere.
Era una terrorista Tamil,
non so se voi conoscete le tigri Tamil,
che cosa sono eccetera,
e l'abbiamo portata a Udine
per farla curare e guarire
per un braccio perso in battaglia.
Il secondo è sempre durante
la guerra civile, in Sri Lanka.
Abbiamo liberato 180 bambini
dal carcere minorile,
bambini che avevano tre,
quattro, cinque, sei anni.
Quindi non si può dire
che avessero commesso un reato.
Queste attività sono avvenute
grazie alla forza della negoziazione.
Di Auxilia,
ma imparata sul meccanismo
dei quattro pilastri.
Perché questo?
Perché negoziare vuol dire
"fare quello che voglio io
alle vostre condizioni".
E quindi è molto simile
al concetto di Flow,
in cui l'obiettivo personale
coincide con l'obiettivo del gruppo.
Diventiamo io e il negoziatore,
la persona che deve negoziare con me,
un tutt’uno.
E facciamo in modo che l’obiettivo mio
corrisponda al suo.
Questa è la negoziazione.
E questa è la rappresentazione
dello stesso meccanismo
inserito all'interno
di un reparto ospedaliero, il mio.
Io sono responsabile
di questo piccolo reparto,
all'ospedale di Cividale del Friuli,
di nefrologia, delle malattie del rene
e quindi ci ricolleghiamo
al concetto di prima.
Questo è il momento in cui
prendo in mano la questione.
E le prestazioni,
con lo stesso personale
e con lo stesso budget,
il primo anno aumentano a 14.000
e poi arriviamo a 23.461.
Si sono praticamente
più che raddoppiate in due anni.
Poi ci stabilizziamo su questo livello:
ormai, probabilmente,
più di così non riusciamo a fare!
Però è un grosso risultato,
sopratutto perché è un ambito pubblico,
dove non c'è la vendita diretta.
Cioè non c'è il meccanismo
in cui io vendo,
e quindi ho un feedback di questo tipo.
È un ambiente pubblico.
Quindi tutta l'attività è dovuta
ed è permessa da quei quattro pilastri.
(Applausi)
Concludo, ho ancora 11 secondi!
Concludo con questa slide.
C'è un bambino che guarda
attraverso un pertugio.
e rappresenta un po' la nostra infanzia,
almeno sicuramente la mia,
che sono stato sempre curioso
di entrare dentro i luoghi bui.
E questo vuol dire che in qualche maniera
tutti noi dobbiamo mantenere
una parte di incoscienza, di curiosità,
di gioco e di leggerezza
per poter raggiungere lo stato di Flow.
Ma soprattutto, la strada difficile,
che è utile che noi prendiamo
per la nostra crescita,
magari è anche molto bella e divertente.
(Applausi)
Grazie a tutti.